so I love this story you guys might have
seen this viral video already cut
dot-com took three grandmothers who have
never smoked weed they handed them a
bong and let's take a look Oh put your
whole face over that yes there do it
like you mean it okay I'm smiling yeah
when I do it I really feel like the
muscles here in my neck seem not as
tight I totally lost track
little bit T I think kicked it up a
notch I think I really inhaled a lot oh
you don't feel as high as they feel look
to me I don't feel to me as high as they
look to me okay clearly I really love
this video if you want to see the full
thing we've got the link in the
description right down below Jimmy as
our resident pot guy our weed guy our
4/20 expert this is a beautiful thing it
isn't this sort of a better commercial
for weed than almost anything else
you've ever seen everyone loves
grandmothers they're having a great
she says her neck pain immediately went
away they're laughing they're being
silly
at one point we didn't include it in
there they refer to to Lindsay Lohan or
by the Cyrus's bleached yeah
they get to there yeah that's what we
takes you to it really like a Jenga yeah
isn't this just a great yeah they're
eating Oreos and whatever this is just a
great commercially that's what Donna
lemon was smelling the obvious smell of
we obvious smell of weed I don't know
why those women aren't in jail I think
they're criminals shouldn't we lock them
up because that's what our culture says
right now that we should lock those
those women up yeah so yeah that is a
great that's a great point that is a
great commercial but the only thing is
about marijuana is you don't need
commercials this is true you know sells
itself
yeah do you think it's funny though that
they gave them a bong to do this now
obviously that looks a bong looks the
funniest but you really don't like right
so when you take a bong hit that's
probably the equivalent I mean it
depends I guess how much you do but
that's really the equivalent smoking
maybe half a joint yeah they probably
would have got stoned from a joint right
yeah definitely they could have just
taken a couple of one aiders maybe well
they did a lot of different things they
smoked a joint Oh didn't they they did
they did the vape pen they they did they
had him and then they put it in the tea
like they did it they had him sort of do
it a different way
weed you don't partake do you know I
have a little a little bit I've gotten
some from my friend at James James Dorf
yeah this game no basically I've had
more weed associated with the TYT crew
people than than anybody else cause I've
smoked a little bit with another another
friend of ours has been on this shows
been on many of the shows here she makes
no about her yes her yes for smoking and
and with her I had my first that was the
first time I thought it was fun I did it
when I was 28 I've said before just try
to get laid and because the girl I
wanted to sleep with was doing it so I
was like yeah but that did nothing but
then mm-hmm but then I did it at 44 and
then I have and I did with you people
say the first time they tried okay hi
yes oh and I was like it was like three
times with that girl it didn't really I
don't know I probably didn't I really
probably probably didn't inhale not
because I was protecting myself I was of
either Freight or didn't do a writer to
know how also the first time this time
around like whatever was too
years ago I instantly threw up like
instantly I threw up and I didn't want
to embarrass myself in front of her so I
like the expression that is tired and no
one wants to use I threw up a little in
my mouth I threw up in my mouth and then
like was like I'll be right back and I
went to a stepped outside and spit out
it was disgusting and we are not going
to merge and then yeah no no and then so
I thought this is horrible and then like
I tried another one and then starting 17
minutes later one of the most fun nights
of my entire life again you laugh
hysterically and that's it so has the
weed thing to me the weed thing is like
the gay marriage thing it took people a
long time to get there but now it's just
gonna happen state-by-state and
everywhere it happens people are gonna
go oh all hell didn't break loose
families didn't fall apart maybe we can
start decriminalizing it and stop
putting people in jail for having weed
which is absurd do you think that's
pretty much how it's gonna go I hope
that's how it goes I mean there's still
a big pushing back against it they just
in Florida right Sheldon Adelson spent 5
million dollars you defeat the medical
marijuana bill somehow defeating it with
43% of the vote yeah like somehow
Florida needed 64 Chakra see what am I
missing with with the people that vote
against it for medical marijuana that's
the part that like yes I'm obviously Pro
weed fine but like that's the part that
I simply cannot understand how can you
tell someone that has cancer or that has
AIDS or something how they can medicate
themselves to feel better what I
literally cannot understand the logic of
that person we like Authority and so we
like the fact that we are somehow these
same people who were Sheldon Adelson I
guarantee you has no stand against
overprescribing you know serotonin based
drugs right he has no problem with how
much xanax somebody takes right 4,000
commercials that are on every
day around maybe he's invested in it
maybe has an economic interest but
somehow I don't think he does but for
clearly a lot of people who aren't
especially we like Authority that's why
we don't like to challenge any of this
stuff that's why this system that we
have here where you just hear a Democrat
arguing with the Republican works
because it's a format that we're
comfortable with it doesn't feel radical
and the notion that none of the only
drugs that were comfortable giving even
though they're clearly more addictive
and more dangerous and mess with your
brain more
we'd that they've been approved they
went through a process our government
doesn't lie to us and the FDA looked at
it and went through a long process and
now it sells it and I got to go to my
doctor and he's in a white coat and he
has to prescribe to me that is a process
I can live with as opposed to this other
thing which may keep you off this more
dangerous drug it may have the same
positive effect that's that we're not
that for some reason we're not coming we
love we love Authority we love listening
to it's why we love Mitt Romney it's why
we love millionaires and it doesn't
matter how much money they make because
if you have money you seem like you're
an authoritative figure and we're
comfortable so is that fundamentally the
the real like it's sort of the oxymoron
of we'd kinda that when all these
commercials that we see all day long
about you know every pill pick a pill
and it's vomiting diarrhea
maybe suicide you might punch your wife
sleepwalking all kinds of crazy
restless legs all that and then they got
another pill for your restless legs all
that but we because none of that so
shouldn't that be the thing that the
weed people are really pushing and not
only can it help you medicinally and
forget the laughing and all that but
also you don't have all that other that
three minutes of side-effects stuff that
they have to put out the tag of every
commercial that that's exactly the
beauty the side effects include general
sense of well-being and sleepiness and
that's it yeah there's no other side
effect by the way I have so I've been
diagnosed with bronchitis about a week
and a half ago and I haven't smoked pot
in a week and a half and I'm going crazy
anybody notice things I'm like oh my god
I haven't smoked pot in five days just
cuz your weed reserves are no but really
you're right you're not crinkle you're
not out there not freedom in my life it
does hasn't inspected me one bit so
that's the beauty of marijuana and it
just goes to show you that by the way
the people who are against medical
marijuana it was been revealed people
like Patrick Kennedy their work for
organizations that are on a take from
oxycontin a cotton of manufacturers so
it's be always be suspect of someone
who's against a cancer patient getting
medicine of course also let's not forget
that Rush Limbaugh was addicted to oxy
time and didn't go to jail or face
anything anything like that
you know weed that's gonna get in a lot
of trouble